Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Style transfer is an interesting problem in
machine learning research where we have two
input images, one for content, and one for
style, and the output is our content image
reimagined with this new style.
The cool part is that the content can be a
photo straight from our camera, and the style
can be a painting, which leads to super fun,
and really good looking results.
This subfield is only a few years old and
has seen a number of amazing papers - style
transfer for HD images, videos, and some of
these forgeries were even able to make professional
art curators think that they were painted
by a real artist.
So, here is a crazy idea -- how about using
style transfer to create caricatures?
Well, this sounds quite challenging.
Just think about it - a caricature is an elusive
art where certain human features are exaggerated,
and generally, the human face needs to be
simplified and boiled down into its essence.
It is a very human thing to do.
So how could possibly an AI be endowed with
such a deep understanding of, for instance,
a human face?
That sounds almost impossible.
Our suspicion is further reinforced as we
look at how previous style transfer algorithms
try to deal with this problem.
Not too well, but no wonder, it would be unfair
to expect great results as this is not what
they were designed for.
But now, look at these truly incredible results
that were made with this new work.
The main difference between the older works
and this one is that one, it uses generative
adversarial networks, GANs in short.
This is an architecture where two neural networks
learn together -- one learns to generate better
forgeries, and the other learns to find out
whether an image has been forged.
However, this would still not create the results
that you see here.
An additional improvement is that we have
not one, but two of these GANs.
One deals with style.
But, it is trained in a way to keep the essence
of the image.
And the other deals with changing and warping
the geometry of the image to achieve an artistic
effect.
This leans on the input of a landmark detector
that gives it around 60 points that show the
location of the most important parts of a
human face.
The output of this geometry GAN is a distorted
version of this point set, which can then
be used to warp the style image to obtain
the final output.
This is a great idea because the amount of
distortion applied to the points can be controlled.
So, we can tell the AI how crazy of a result
we are looking for.
Great!
The authors also experimented applying this
to video.
In my opinion, the results are incredible
for a first crack at this problem.
We are probably just one paper away from an
AI automatically creating absolutely mind
blowing caricature videos.
Make sure to have a look at the paper as it
has a ton more results and of course, every
element of the system is explained in great
detail there.
And if you enjoyed this episode and you would
like to access all future videos in early
access, or, get your name immortalized in
the video description as a key supporter,
please consider supporting us on patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers.
The link is available in the video description.
We were able to significantly improve our
video editing rig, and this was possible because
of your generous support.
I am so grateful, thank you so much!
And, this is why every episode ends with the
usual quote...
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!